Changi Airport Singapore one of the
largest transportation hubs in Asia and
voted the best airport in the world is
about to launch what's been touted as an
industry game-changer
the ambition we have set for force are
presented terminal 4 with full
automation passengers will be able to
serve themselves from check-in to
boarding today Changi is one step closer
to changing the aviation model how do
you create something for that moment
that you didn't expect but to deliver
the airport's latest terminal the team
must conquer the unfamiliar we need to
green up 50,000 square meters of
greenery it is five football fields
using cutting-edge technology they are
breaking new ground so we're actually
lifting up a small car yeah
to redefine what air travel is all about
expectations are very high everyone
chun-hee to continue to be best at what
in the world
[Music]
tiny tropical island logistics hub and
financial powerhouse Singapore is also
home to Changi Airport for six years in
a row Changi has been voted the best
airport in the world
every week more than seven thousand
flights connect over a million
passengers to four hundred cities
worldwide the airport recorded a new
high of 62 million passengers in 2017
globally the number of air travelers is
set to double to 7.2 billion by 2035 to
meet this demand Changi is expanding in
four months time their latest
development will open terminal for a
two-story space packed with art and
greenery features that will be one of
the world's first fully automated
terminals morning guys have they get
stuff I've been training operating the
door for 500 body we do see very
profound travels across board the thirst
for speed the transfer efficiency the
thirst for being able to have control of
that one journey even through the
airport and automation was is what key
answer to such demands general manager
for trials Kelvin tan is leading the
charge ensuring the team is ready for
its big opening
today 200 volunteers will take part in
an experiment to trial the new
technology in place during a team is a
little jittery we were having trouble
participants for members of public who
are totally unfamiliar systems in the
first time they are interacting with all
this equipment these volunteers are
meant to simulate the journey of
passengers and must pass through all new
automated stages check-in bag drop
immigration and boarding all this
without coming into contact with ground
staff having worked at Changi Airport
for six years
today is kelvins ultimate test
it is easier for the more tech-savvy or
a young ones but we wanted to make sure
that even an ideogram model could go
through it with as minimal assistance as
possible
a suspicious follow the step to me we
are part of Singapore Changi Airport the
technology have changed from the middle
wire and after the beautiful
while the volunteers prepare for the
experience teams are working around the
terminal to bring it to life
[Music]
this is pedal element number eight start
with a red one and now swollen well we
have automated kiosk check-in soil and
so forth
even though art is also high-tech Daniel
foo and police and have been involved in
Terminal four since its conception in
2012 in the airport the foundation is
having sufficient capacity we know that
we wanted to do something quite
different for Terminal four we have a
philosophy of rethinking travel we want
to push further our boundaries to look
at innovative concepts and also the
latest technology on how we can further
enhance passenger experience the team
commissioned artists to make pieces
specifically for Terminal four artworks
are aimed at keeping stress levels of
passengers down somehow raga will avoid
trouble as a passenger I'm always very
stressed on what we want is to actually
have selected our pieces sprinkled in
Terminal four that in itself reduces the
stress of the passenger to enjoy the
journey to top it off a centerpiece that
will span over 200 meters floating above
the central galleria designed after
Singapore's national flower the orchid
it is called the petal clouds
[Music]
once complete it will be one of the
world's largest kinetic sculptures so
when you're designing this kind of
kinetic sculptures the physical
materiality in space is hugely important
they're not machines
the work was conceived by UC ankhs Leyva
the designer responsible for the kinetic
rain in Changi Airport's terminal 1 the
whole thing is definitely a sculpture
first and foremost and it's kinetic uses
design work begins with animation and
computer modeling we then try different
kinds of material combinations did an
on-site test during the constructions to
get really the right matching perfect
solution so the project here is very
much pushing the limits in all
directions
[Music]
the team needs to first assemble all
custom-made components flown in from
Germany 5,000 components 96 elements
strung up by 384 ropes about 200 mottos
all consumed away from the passages I
it's a bit lively Gloria Libre is for
smaller for small boys this one is a
little bit more complicated
today is the first time that the team
are lifting up the final petals one
element itself weighs about 40 kg and if
you talk about 16 of these for one cloud
it's about half ton so we're actually
lifting up a small car yeah in this case
so I'm pretty excited but also at same
time pretty nervous
lifting the petals are 192 motors
located in the rafters above we have all
32 engines to be online so [ __ ] loads
the first element you mean one exactly
can you lift up only one
three years of building the petal clouds
culminates now once the motors are
engaged they will contract the cable and
pull up the pebbles I just have to make
sure it doesn't fall
[Music]
each petal element is made of
lightweight aluminium suspended on steel
cables that can hold 40 times its weight
[Music]
finally the clouds are literally moving
out with very smooth I'm very happy
today as work continues on mechanical
petals
attention turns to living ones we need
to green up fifty thousand square meters
of greenery that is five football fields
if you put all of them together it's
almost a half a million plants from
shrubs right up to six seven meter trees
in tea for itself to help with this task
is Changi Airport's very own nursery
spread over 120,000 square meters it
grows over 500 species of plants for the
four terminals in charges head of
horticulture Kaja Nazim Udine who's been
working at Changi Airport for 12 years
Wallace loved outdoors I don't working
with plants or working with the nature
wildlife always loved it Changi was the
first in the world to introduce Airport
Gardens in doing so replicating the
vision for Singapore as a garden city
Chinese the first stop into the country
in the last stop out of the country so
where else to show your current cities
starts at 8
you walk around many apples do you find
this place butterfly garden or sunflower
gardens to go and relax before your next
flight greenery plans for terminal 4 are
bigger than anything the team has
previously taken on for over three years
Carter and his team have been sourcing
and growing plants and trees that will
line the terminal walkways you're
walking among the trees it was a
fantastic feeling and we knew that this
was the one that's gonna make a
difference to t4 but lower light levels
of indoor gardens pose a huge challenge
careful planning is required to ensure
plants thrive once at the terminal hello
I'm live in you know two weeks weeks
three weeks okay great
well you have built the [ __ ] house and
you have dark black paintings to cut
down the light depending on the plant
types you cut down 30% of lights on we
come down 50% and leaving them there for
what six months to one year or even to
18 months depending on the plant
one tree that has adapted is this 12
meter tall Agathis today the team has to
transport it 25 kilometres from the
nursery to the airport
it is a very slow process or we do one
three a day or two trees a day depending
on the size of the tree
we will speak is to lose them while
you're transporting to break a branch or
you break half a tree if it I don't know
how stressful is that or trees but it is
obviously very stressful for me in my
team because we want to ensure that
every trees brought into the terminal in
a good condition
terminal 4 will be Changi Airport's
greenest ever terminal displaying
Singapore's reputation as a Garden City
the next key ingredient a 12 metre tall
agatha's tree one of over half a million
plants that will create a massive garden
inside the terminal
[Music]
the renina you get and clear out of them
mostly the first thing you do is plant
it as quickly as you can damage or
stress to the tree could prevent it from
adapting to its new indoor home it's
been cared for at the nursery for two
and a half years you don't want to keep
it too long in this it's the most
critical and most stressful for me we
have two more guys watch the practice
[Music]
this 12 meter tree weighs 3,000
kilograms as heavy as an adult
rhinoceros oh yeah
all hands are required on deck they just
get him slowly very mystery takes you
like two to three hours to position a
tree just position it correctly into the
hole and then the big big part of all
this isn't doing the straightening up
there's to be some excitement in life so
this exactly planting trees finally one
of the tallest trees in terminal 4 is in
position to the last 4 hours whatever
and I think she'll come here just fine
give it a lot of money it will look like
the tree is being there from day one
Carter and his team still have half a
million more plants to settle into
terminal 4 back at the trials the
volunteers are testing out Changi
Airport's newest features they will next
need to deposit their bags a process
traditionally handled by a check-in
agent is now being automated automation
is used in various parts of travel it
just hasn't really been strung together
in a coherent fashion as what we're
trying to do nt4
it wasn't easy for us the aunt that many
reference us around the world available
for us to look at
the automated bank drop machines are
capable of handling up to five thousand
four hundred bags hourly go Chen II must
make sure they work fast and precisely
to get our machines fully ready me
please thousands and thousands of packs
through the full system
without the watchful eye of an agent the
team had to develop an alternative to
accurately verify all the bags the
solution utilizing special cameras
normally found in a games console device
these three are present connect to and
connect three okay each each connect
will take its own 3d view of the back
all the three images will get stitched
using three cameras the system forms a
3d image of the back a million data
points are analyzed in seconds these
cameras allow us to have that bit of our
security ensures that only the right
stuff get accepted into this the system
if the image exceeds the dimensions the
bag will get rejected and it won't be
processed
[Music]
if the bag is within limits it will be
allowed to enter the system with man and
machine working in tandem the volunteers
have successfully checked themselves in
a volunteer is being paged
okay the papa rasta has gone off we are
looking for particular passenger she has
been asked to consider information
counter the volunteers were given dummy
bags at the start of the trials what
they don't know is that within some of
these bags are prohibited items if
there's anything suspicious that we pick
up in the back we have to call the
passenger for reconciliation essentially
is asking the passengers abut his or her
bank we just need to make sure that the
item we saw is that the indiscriminating
that cannot be unlived in their aircraft
coming through
but in today's trials the volunteer is
nowhere to be found
okay stop there - recon station is all
about time so is how quickly can we
assemble the resources to bring them
back to the reconciliation room how
quick can we find the passenger Dhokla
passenger being a passenger down from
the body get to the recon station wagon
finally the checks can begin kommen
prohibited items found in check-in backs
include flammable items terminal for
security personnel have to be on their
toes to spot them when the bags are
screened in today's trials even if the
volunteers have really role-playing are
you [ __ ] us who needs a thousand
seriously this you know whether we play
out I think the responses from the
various parties were earning Mira
expectations and they reacted
accordingly
[Music]
Singapore's Changi Airport is gearing up
for a brand new terminal counting down
to opening the team are ensuring the
security of new automated systems at the
trials the focus is now on the
immigration stage each time our
passenger is entering into an area of a
higher security you have to show proof
that your identity is indeed available
in Chinese other terminals security
staff check a passengers likeness
against their passport picture at
Terminal four the team has made a
breakthrough
if I want to do a verification of your
thumbprint right now I need to first
have in my database a record of your
thumbprint for facial recognition simple
I just have to have a passport photo or
any kind of photo for that matter the
facial recognition gates use a matching
process using the eyes as an anchor the
technology analyzes prominent facial
features and calculates the distances
between them the photo taken and the
passport must match to allow the person
through so this person over here Ian see
this point on his face was slightly
angled what the system does is
intelligent enough to automatically move
those points back to where they should
be and from there it creates a full
frontal symmetrical image that looks
something like this
but today the technology is facing
teething problems some volunteers have
not been allowed through the gates so
this is us this what will be my
reduction yes correct
I try to understand if it's got to do
with the passports quality passengers
behavior ergonomics from this data we
are able to to track the reasons
surrounding it there we can we can fix
the problem long security queues are a
major stress point for travelers as
Terminal four occupies the smallest land
area of all Chinese terminals the team
opted for a centralized screening area
with over 20,000 people eventually
coming through daily the challenge for
project manager Poli son is to ensure
fast operations and few cues passengers
get quite anxious about going through a
security screening our key focus for
this area is to transform it from a
stressful to a stress-free area
a new automated train system helps
passengers quickly deposit their items
Terminal four also makes Changi the
first airport in the world to employ
computer tomography or CT scanners for
security more often found in hospitals
these scanners provide a detailed 3d
perspective of a bags contents CT x-rays
will also help speed up the entire
screening process of passengers while
solving a major inconvenience passengers
no longer have to remove laptops and
tablets from their bags
the final addition to the screening area
is a 17 meter giant immersive wall its
8.3 million pixels will showcase the
destinations terminal 4 will service
around the region the whole ambience of
being very peaceful helping passengers
kind of reduce the stresses of flying
while the trial lists keep their cool
hidden away from everyone another team
is being challenged by the trials this
time down in the baggage facility okay
you know yeah this is terminal fours
state of the art baggage handling area
thousands of bags will come through
these belts hourly one every second
banned tags with the corresponding
flight details are autonomously scanned
they are then routed on trays at two
point three meters a second around the
conveyors until they reach their belt so
in energy systems where they are for
automation there are always base cases
where some Dex tactics are not being
read in a situation where the barcode
video is unable to be the best taxiway
they require menuhin intubation in the
rare occurrence the tag is unable to be
read bags are routed to the manual
encoder room can we just check whether
our of and manual corners are being able
to cope with the hive Olympics preparing
for every eventualities today's trial
will stress test the manual system with
200 bags when mx2 up and the process is
slow increased resource available not
being able to reach the flag and that
will translate the best messenger
experience when the RNA will received a
fax when they reach the other
destination
[Music]
twenty one point six million bags were
reported lost or misdirected worldwide
in 2016 to reduce lost bags of Changi
engineer co-chair one and his team must
be fully prepared to make sure no delays
occur Keep Calm and biggest epic a
relief to decide what needs to be done
if you panic then probably everything oh
gosh I need to scan the vague linear
very fast
I don't do fast the passenger cannot get
to me
can we see how the menu encoders are
doing if these are being good
hey so unlike a good job
these bags had now enroute to the trial
flight all except one
we only receive one diamond pieces which
you'll be able to check the last piece
for us across 10 kilometers of conveyor
belts
Sherwin's team must race to hunt one
missing back
you
[Music]
Changi Airport's first fully automated
terminal is close to opening trials are
reaching their climax with one simulated
flight ready to depart but down below in
the baggage handling area a bag is
missing they only receive one by nine
pieces which you'll be able to check the
last piece was tech number is KT 1 0 3 4
7 0
in a case of Changi Airport because of
the skills of the number of XM you saw
the system cinema Lucia miss finding one
bag among 4,000 in the system might seem
like looking for a needle in a haystack
tell me take a look where the current
patient of X's but there's a secret in
the way the bags are sorted at a baggage
control we have all the information this
needed to be able track where the box is
in the systems it is actually organizing
a disorganized way the bags are placed
on individual numbered trays tray
numbers and bag tag codes are paired up
so when a bag needs to be found from the
control room
a simple search reveals the location and
the status of the bag before discharging
it to the right destination
just they indicate another system
terminal 4 is one of the first terminals
in Asia to use this type of sortation
technology the basis yeah decision we
have received all 200 pieces back thank
you so much
every single show is important because
when actual situation really happens
ensures that were well-prepared and
therefore the passenger will probably
not realize it even though there is a
slight foreigner systems the trial
flight is ready to depart volunteers now
pass through the automated boarding
gates and mentor flight on Air Asia and
with that their virtual holiday is over
if you want speed then that's where
technology will come in and that has to
change with times because we are moving
forward and a lot of technological
changes I embrace to change the system
here is the more sophisticated this is
really a good simulation exercise before
they implement it
next the key findings are digested by
the team if we open a terminal we for
such a robust and rigorous program I
could imagine people getting lost in the
terminal but they probably can't even
find out way to the check-in this do you
start realizing that hey I know a great
attraction of the kiosk
this backdrop submit as a wolf is the
texture for the first five nights all
the facts from from check-in render the
form is incorrect because only contains
seven digits so all these virtual system
can always attack more work needs to be
done to get these systems to speed
[Music]
7,000 more volunteers will come through
the gates before this billion-dollar
terminal is ready for its first
passengers we both are there were some
areas where improvements so we can
address them early and by the time comes
when people opens everything up this
movie running
[Music]
reflecting Singapore's identity is a key
element of terminal 4 story we are a
very unique culture with melting pot of
you know different ethnicities different
races different religions one of the
challenge of design DeForest how do we
make this terminal microcosm of the
whole Singapore city also being an
introduction to our foreign passengers
who's coming through our doors into
Singapore
to do so the Changi Team have turned to
history enthusiasts tan way Shin
infusing Singapore's culture into the
design
they are replicating colorful pre-war
shop houses that line the streets of
downtown Singapore there is rich history
you know that we have and we want to
share everybody we value our heritage
for you on the preservers and you rather
exhibited and enjoy everyone way Shin
has 30 years of set design experience
and knows what is needed to bring that
culture to life
it has to be authentic nummies that you
have to detail detailing is the key to
everything and having that details and
you could have brilliant proportion and
get the everything right not a colors
that hold dressing to it this is the
Heritage zone it will celebrate
Peranakan culture the product of inter
marriages between locals and earlier
immigrants from China India and Western
countries sparking off a distinctive
blend of designs now presented here in
the terminal least significant elements
in it the birds the Phoenix the color
and its release perfect the final
element of the design is a concealed
screen that doubles as a digital theater
stage for a six minute musical all to
entertain and preserve a culture unique
to the region
I realized that way back then no real
fishing village yet we have our to give
us you know you know hope you will
inspire our just search for the heritage
in it and then learn more about which
Singapore's history now into woven into
terminal 4
[Music]
terminal 4 is now just one month away
from opening with Changi Airport's world
leading reputation at stake it is
imperative its latest expansion is a
success
let's see Dog Night one final touches
are underway to prepare for the big
opening
[Music]
breathing life into the spaces are half
a million plants with terminal for now
changhie's greenest versed in available
soil around images for the plants to
thrive in their new home Carter and his
team need to make sure the soil is
well-drained and some days you overwater
in some days you underwater we don't
want it to go too much water because you
don't have direct Sun and the water will
not evaporate that mask and then we
specially built in misting and focus in
our landscapes to ensure that the plants
get sufficient humidity gone are the
days when you have one gardener going
around doing manual watering throughout
the day automated watering will keep the
plants growing at optimum level
[Music]
including these 12 meter tall trees all
160 of them planted by Kaja and his team
the priests with this height will always
be a wall for passengers having people
standing around and admiring your tree
it's almost like an someone standing
next to painting and admiring a painting
and yours is not opinions is a living
thing every day you have to ensure that
the tree survival for horticulture is
the job is never finished it's just one
chapter of a book that runs into many
chapters
it's like pregnancy and giving birth so
you've just given but you have to brace
your child all around terminal falls
features emerge now with the orchid
petal motif on show across the spaces
the stage is set for lead designer you
see to finish work on the centerpiece
the petal clouds one of the largest
kinetic sculptures in the world at the
moment we are one side so we suddenly
have all the physical parameters of the
space to factor in and think about just
the right adjustment either it's a
monster in your face or it's elegant
using custom-made software that controls
the movement of the petal elements the
team has to synchronize the light
settings and motion of all six clouds to
a bespoke music composition pedicle
consistent approximately 3000 pages of
software coding and it is tantamount to
actually building a satellite in space
here it's needed to move 4,000 kilograms
of metal gracefully people spend maybe
two hours there put they have their mind
maybe already somewhere else so how do
you create something for that moment
that is special that is surprising that
is something that you didn't expect you
seize ambitious artwork requires
incredible precision the motors contract
and release the cables over nine meters
giving movement to the pedals and
powering up the lights within them it's
an I think yeah I think we still need
more lights to us kazuto-san for not on
the notion that looks good when I first
saw it moving we kind of you know you
get goose pimples and this kind of thing
was if it works for me like that I hope
that will it'll have the same effect on
many others
ah does not need to be very esoteric as
long as I'm able to touch someone's life
just one person is all totally worth it
because someone a TLD appreciated it
understood it and roll that this is
something that's better its centerpiece
now fully operational Terminal four is
ready for the first passengers
[Music]
[Music]
through four years of development a
4,000 strong team has transformed this
225,000 square meter space now terminal
four is born we don't built new
terminals every other day so this is
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to do a
really good job in this new terminal
today Chinese new systems carefully
developed automated technology are put
into use opening day also welcomes a new
member of the Changi Team automated
cleaning equipment or ace for short four
robots are able to autonomously map the
floor areas sense obstacles and clean up
to 1,600 square meters per hour all with
minimal or no supervision the real test
for the day is how quickly the
passengers can be processed do you
always have somebody in our doing
manually doing this we but this is
totally automatic
[Music]
it's way more efficient we always use
computers anyways so it's pretty easy
800 flights a week will jet off to 20
different countries around the region
[Music]
what if the first flights is leaving
soon behind the scenes
Jenny's team is keeping a watchful eye
over the automated systems to make sure
all passengers get to the gate on time
[Music]
there is a consistent pattern it's
always happening to this particular gate
to confirm that this kid is fine on
ground yeah although working
autonomously the facial recognition
technology can be monitored from the
back-office and the team can mitigate
any errors before they occur so usually
if we pick up some indications of
devices being unavailable from this
system we can very quickly zoom in to
understand why the problem is to see if
we have a quick fix for it usually they
are not apparent to a difficult
passenger so for now it looks to be okay
it seems to be okay
back on the ground Kelvin tan is on the
lookout to ensure that no hiccups occur
everything is going smooth going as
planned
adding the hard work put in the really
trials and order system has paid off his
four years of hard work are now being
realized
the ambition vision that we have set 444
was unprecedented the one who want to
open a new terminal with such complex
systems in place and I'm going to give
up while time is needed before novelty
becomes the norm passengers are getting
to grips with the terminals new
technology it's quite obviously a new
thing for most people to have automation
from the start to the end of the
departure journey over time as more
people get used to it we will be able to
then focus our resources on those people
that really need elderly or younger
children
[Music]
Changi Airport's evolution will continue
further expansion will soon bring
overall capacity to up to 135 million
passengers a year
we need to use t4 as an intermediate
juncture to test some of these new
concepts new technology so that when we
land what if I really know exactly what
we are putting into this new big
terminal
King Porus terminal vets will be an
emblem of how do two terminals could
also look like pre fast technology to
ambitious art and installations and half
a million plants this terminal of
tomorrow has come to life
[Music]
all passengers and check-in backs
accounted for time for takeoff
a new era for Changi Airport begins
[Music]
I think very clearly recipe for success
in China is clearly for the people and
the passion for the passengers I think
is also a national pride that we won
China to continue to be the best I point
[Music]
[Music]